[Música]
seguimos con nuestro segmento de
análisis esto en el marco de la entrega
de los premios Nobel y nos acompaña más
Romero salamar Qué bueno tenerla aquí en
nuestro estudio nuevamente seguimos con
esta serie de los premios Nobel esta vez
con el premio Nobel de química Buenos
días Raúl si lo hemos estado anunciando
de nuevo como desde el principio fue
para los estadounidenses Barry sharkless
y Carolina bertotxi y el danés morten
meldall no dos curiosidades Barry Shark
Place ya ganó el Nobel de química en
2001 y Caroline bertoce es solo la
octava mujer en toda la historia de los
premios Nobel de química que ha recibido
este galardón desde 1901 hace más de 100
años Charles imeldall se los considera
padres de la química clic que es un
nombre pues bastante divertido para
explicar algo básicamente que hicieron
muy fácil algo que hasta ahora era muy
difícil luego profundizamos en ello y
bertotxi es conocida porque llevó todas
estas herramientas desarrolladas por sus
predecesores a otro nivel hasta hacerlo
dentro Pues de las o de los organismos
vivos parece que estemos como siempre en
estos días hablando de ciencia ficción
Pero esto de la construcción de
moléculas es algo que se hace todo el
tiempo desde hace mucho tiempo para
crear materiales crear plásticos para
crear también farmacias o sea productos
farmacéuticos no medicamentos y para que
nos hagamos una idea muy rápida y saber
de que estamos hablando no recordemos
que la molécula es la agrupación de
átomos que todavía conserva sus
propiedades de la sustancia a la que
pertenece por ejemplo una molécula de
agua es H2O tiene dos átomos de
hidrógeno uno de oxígeno y son muchas
moléculas de agua las que crean el agua
pues para que nosotros la podamos ver y
tocar entonces Bueno pues los grandes
avances de estos tres científicos están
Precisamente en sus herramientas y
métodos para la construcción de
moléculas Ahora sí hablemos mar de la
clínica
es una solución básicamente no es una
una salida un rompecabezas que había
perseguido a los químicos durante muchas
décadas durante mucho tiempo no para
unir moléculas en las que se necesitan
reacciones químicas y durante mucho
tiempo Eso era un proceso fatigoso
costoso dispendiador de tiempo de
material generador de residuos no algo
que hacía todo muy difícil especialmente
por ejemplo los átomos de carbono
totalmente presentes en lo que es la
materia orgánica y que son pues muy
reticentes digamos a dejarse manejar
como uno quiere entonces ahí sharpless
fue el que dijo Bueno en vez de intentar
usar estos átomos Unidos átomos de
carbono que es muy difícil usemos la
pequeñas estructuras moleculares ya de
átomos de carbono que son como una
especie de ladrillos más grandes que
sirven para construir con mucho más
facilidad enganchar y enlazar estas
moléculas con reacciones pues que no
sean a procesos largos costosos y que
también sean mucho más amigables con el
medio ambiente pero es que luego además
llega también pues una de las joyas de
la corona de la química y que se premia
Precisamente en este Premio Nobel que es
una reacción especial Tiene un nombre
rarísimo se llama ciclo adición
alquinoacida catalizada por cobre pero
ya vamos a explicar Qué significa
básicamente quieres unir dos cosas no
dos moléculas como vemos en este gráfico
a un lado le pones ácida que es la unión
de varias varios átomos de nitrógeno y
al otro alquila alquino Perdón que son
la unión de varios átomos de carbono
entonces con ayuda de cobre como
catalizador como ayuda algo que ayuda a
hacer la reacción química se juntan como
si fuera como vemos un cinturón de
seguridad eso hace una estructura mucho
más estable llamada triazol pues que
sirve para unir moléculas de forma fácil
barata y que tiene hoy en día se usa de
hecho ampliamente tiene muchísimas
implicaciones para crear materiales de
medicamentos y eso es básicamente el
trabajo de Charles y de metal hablamos
de ellos dos pero qué papel juega cara
lo inventoxie sí la octava mujer
recordemos en recibir el premio Nobel de
química en toda la historia ella lo que
hace es llevar todo esto que ya
suficientemente mágico a otro nivel no
lo hace dentro de los organismos vivos
por ejemplo dentro de la célula pero hay
un problema y es que para esta reacción
que estábamos hablando se necesita el
cobre cobre es tóxico para los
organismos vivos
Entonces ella logra encontrar una forma
para no tener que usar el cobre
modificando uno de estos grupos
moleculares en una forma como circular y
así poder engancharlo dentro de las
células sin que las células sufran
ninguna alteración por hacerles esto por
ejemplo Qué hizo en su propia
investigación ella lo que hizo fue
centrarse en los glicanos los glicanos
son una especie de azúcares unos
carbohidratos que están en la superficie
de las células de que juegan un papel en
el sistema inmune pero no sabíamos no se
sabía muy bien cuál no era todavía un
misterio qué hace ella pues para poder
investigarlos lo que hace es hace entrar
un azúcar dentro de la célula con uno de
estos lados del cinturón de seguridad
digamos la célula lo procesa coge este
azúcar que ya le incorpora por si lo
ponen uno de los glicanos que él salen
digamos en la superficie y luego coge
una molécula digamos fluorescente Que
brille le pone el otro lado del cinturón
de seguridad y hacen clic una vez este
glicano está fuera de la célula entonces
pues que tienes tienes glicanos
fluorescentes que por lo tanto son mucho
más fáciles rastrear de ver y entender
lo que hacen Y de qué nos sirve esto hoy
en día más pues decíamos que esta
química clic lleva mucho tiempo ya
sirviendo para muchas cosas lo mismo con
la química Bio ortogonal que por cierto
es todo este proceso que hace bertotx y
de poder hacerlo dentro de células o de
organismos vivos pero hay cosas y hay
implicaciones gigantes por ejemplo en
tecnologías de la salud que sabemos que
aquí pues nos interesan además
especialmente por ejemplo estos glicanos
fluorescentes de alguna forma pueden
servir como biomarcadores por ejemplo
para saber en qué estadio está el cáncer
o cómo se desarrolla también se pueden
hacer anticuerpos que se enganchen a los
tumores por ejemplo luego inyectar
terapias que directamente vayan a hacer
este clic y por ejemplo pues ser mucho
más dirigido no no dañar tanto el resto
del cuerpo Entonces como decíamos
implicaciones gigantes a nivel de
tecnologías de la salud y de hecho pues
los responsables del premio Nobel
cerraban de una forma muy bonita su
explicación diciendo que estos inventos
No son los son elegantes inteligentes de
innovadores sino que además son
realmente beneficiosos para toda la
humanidad mar como siempre Gracias por
información la Quiero felicitar por su
capacidad de entender toda esta
información en tiempo récord algo de
hora y media para después explicarnos
absolutamente todo